c'est un gros chantier qui s'activent
dans ce petit espace de 500 rené
lévesque ouest
le rêve des rythmes à son équipe devient
enfin réalité
après avoir frôlé la catastrophe juillet
le comité olympique canadien présidé par
marcel au but lens en grande pompe la
maison olympique à peine deux mois plus
tard un scandale éclate
le président du comité olympique
canadien démissionne sur fond d'
allégations d'harcèlement sexuel des
millions de dollars sont déjà allongé le
coeur du projet reste à faire le premier
appel d'offres échoue
l'équipe se demande s'il faut tout
laisser tomber et on se repose
est ce qu'on livre c'est à présent sur
tous les changements qu'on a eu autant
dans la gouvernance dans les deux
chiffres en 2015 et répond à la question
la réponse à la question c'est oui on le
fait deux ans et demi plus tard la firme
gsm reprend le flambeau
le dessinateur technique l'équipe
prépare un projet entièrement revu voici
l'une des trois zones qui sera
accessible aux visiteurs
elle raconte le parcours des athlètes
plus spectaculaire que les plans
initiaux
la salle qui sera dans le hall d'entrée
a toutefois été réduite pour permettre
aux employés de l'édifice de mieux
circuler
l'équipe prépare aussi une portion plus
interactive qui proposera aux visiteurs
une immersion dans l'univers olympique
grâce à une technologie de haute
printemps le tout un scénario qui
reprend un peu le moment de l'arrivée
dans le stade pour les athlètes alors on
faire on fait revivre
un peu oui ce moment d'angoissé de
préparatifs des jeux mais aussi des
moments de tension deux défaites de
blessure et cetera jusqu'à l'arrivée et
la victoire les visiteurs circuleront
donc d'une salle à l'autre
le comité olympique canadien assure que
le budget de 12 millions sera respectée
plus de huit millions proviennent de
fonds publics l'ouverture est prévue ce
printemps ici julie marceau radio canada
montréal